[Applause]
hi everybody how's it going out there
hi so no my name is Suzanne aka kitten
on the keys and I'm here to warm you up
so I know I love this so my first song
is from 1929 and it's called taint no
sin to take off your skin and dance
around in your bones that's getting
awful naked folks
[Music]
golly I certainly do like this Baldwin
grand piano here whoa fancy dancing
named thisand that and help you take up
lots of I'm the friend of dancin when
it's hard shove your dancing fool guru
loves to dance but can't keep cool there
in mind this idea that I've got
[Music]
when it gets too hot comfort and can't
eat ice cream cones take no senton take
off your skin dance around your bones
with the laser syncopation of the music
softly mouths
danielson take off your skin dance
around your bones
polar bears you know not green up in
Greenland but they got the right idea
they think it's great to refrigerate
while we go commit down here be like
family baby babies on the south sea
traffic zones tango sing take off your
skin and dance dance around your bones
[Music]
when you're callin up your sweetie
on the telephone channel soon take off
your skin dance around your bones when
you're on a crowded dance floor Neath
red-hot saxophones Taino simply take on
your skin and dance around in your bones
take a look at the girls while they're
dancing notice the way that they're
dressed they wear silk and close without
any hose and nobody knows the rest that
is shocking if a gal bears xr8 dresses
and shows everything the check out chain
those seven the tag off your skin then
you can dance dance around you bones
thank you are you getting a little
warmer I certainly hope so
now this next song is so popular in the
rest homes I plan it's so good but I
need your help
are you ready to get your inner songbird
to come out people okay this next song
is from the late teens and it's called
let's all sing like the birdies sing so
I'll be kind is a little waltz II thing
and I'll be um singing and kind of
cueing you and you can chirp and tweet
and whistle and just have a good old
time so we all like to pucker up and
blow right okay
oh let's all sing like the birdie sing
sweet tweet tweet tweet tweet
that would be your part okay so I'll
start that again and when you hear this
little melody you'll be like oh oh my
god that's me let's all sing like the
birdie sing
tweet tweet tweet tweet tweet oh my god
you're awesome let's all sing like the
[ __ ]
tweet tweet tweet tweet tweet
let's all verbal like nightingales give
your throat a treat
take your time from the birds now you
all know the words what are they
tweet tweet tweet tweet tweet tweet
tweet tweet tweet oh you're good sweet
sweet sweet sweet sweet
let's all warble like nightingales if
your throat a treat
take your time from the birds now you
all know the words let's make them hear
it all the way in gavin newsom office
across the street and that little green
red building how does it go speech tweet
tweet tweet tweet
[Music]
you are awesome ok I guess I'm going
through perimenopause up here it was
that or I've totally have warmed you up
so um I have one more song it's gonna be
great it's it's a standard must do it's
San Francisco now I ain't no Jeanette
MacDonald she can really sing SuperDuper
loud and you know I love this long-term
thinking think I've been doing some
long-term thinking and I've been storing
some nuts okay it's been a long time
since I wore this dress I'm like oh
[Music]
sounds Christmasy it only takes a tiny
corner
this great big world to make a place
that you love my home upon the hill I
find I love you still I've been away but
now I'm back to tell you everybody
Sam Francisco open your Golden Gate on
that no stranger fee outside your door
San Francisco other places only make me
love you best tell me you're the heart
of all the goal Dan west of San
Francisco
[Music]
San Francisco thank you for singing
along and you're all excellent excellent
participators so this is lost landscapes
for five and tonight we have Rick
Preminger of the browser library in
archives and this is put on by the long
now foundation and they do have a
monthly seminar series and I would like
to welcome to the stage for the second
year in a row mr. Stewart brand of the
long now foundation
[Applause]
this is a rowdy sounding audience but I
learned something else tonight before
the show I was out wandering in the
lobby and what I see is this long thin
beautifully organized line going all the
way around the lobby and down the hall
over here and I asked one of the staff
here Wow who organized that and they
said nobody did anything the audience
organized themselves that way which
makes me think that a long term thinking
audience is really into Fairplay and
queuing up or something like that or
maybe it's the Rick Prelinger audience
ah that's what's really going on people
who have respect the past respect the
president and the other people in the
present with them that's cool you know
maybe a mystery will be answered tonight
the mystery to me is you go into a
restaurant and there's photographs of
the town in San Francisco that's San
Francisco and they're old photographs
they're decades old even if the
restaurant has only been there two weeks
and so what is the message it seems like
the restaurant is trying to saying we're
a part of this great dynamic city and
one of the wonderful things about cities
is they change all the time and we're
here to blend in with that and respect
that and we hope that our restaurant
lasts longer than two weeks and that it
will be here to be part of photographs
40 years from now that happens to
approximately none of them so that sort
of fastening the past on the wall is
some kind of reaching or grasping or
clutching for the future and I guess
that's part of what brings us back year
after year to see these old images of
Ric Bellinger's and here they come
thanks so much for coming it's hard to
believe that this is the fifth lost
landscape show I wonder where we'll be
in five more years nominations are
welcome I'm going to begin with a few
shoutouts I'd like to introduce our
three commentators these are people who
have the privilege or the burden of
carrying a microphone and they're
sitting up there there's woody Labonte
from the western neighborhoods project
there's Eadie Holmes of the San
Francisco mime troupe longtime
troublemaker
and for the first time in the press box
Megan Alyson Wade native San Franciscan
and urban historian thank you in advance
I'd also like to thank the long now
people who've worked very very hard the
amazing tech crew here at herps theater
a highly professional venue Suzanne for
the song and John law for the dogs
um so two little points of business
number one this show will be repeated
sometime early next year I don't have a
date yet but at the spanking-new
Internet Archive gathering room at Fond
student Clemente so if you're on my
mailing list you'll hear about it so for
all the people that couldn't come
there's gonna be one more chance
second on January 12 of next year at
counter pulse there will be the first
West Coast screening of Lost landscapes
of Detroit which is an interesting show
complicated and kind of I think it's a
well it's a thought-provoking and smart
footage I don't know about the comment
anyway
but it's I hope you can come see that
that's counter pulse at ninth and
mission on January 12th so this is a
seminar on long term thinking and I'm
going to begin with a few long-term
thoughts to maybe keep in mind
throughout this experience and shortly
we'll begin as I assembled this year's
show one thing I was reminded was that
it doesn't only show what has changed in
San Francisco but what remains the same
we are still a port of entry for people
and for goods even if most of them now
arrive by air and land instead of by sea
we're still a place where people come to
make art and culture especially unusual
art and as it was with Playland and the
Barbary Coast we love the places where
we go to party and to play but we tend
to shut them down when they spend too
far out of control
and we're also lucky to live in a place
where nature and culture rub right up
against one another which is a pleasure
but it gets complicated when the Coyotes
run loose in the parks so for these and
other reasons I often wonder whether it
the title lost landscapes does justice
to our city it's easier to list what's
disappeared it's easier to say how much
fun we used to have easier to long for a
glowing irretrievable past easier to do
all these and more than it is to think
hard thoughts about growth and change so
I want to say that the city has a
history like none other and that's why
there's over 900 of us in this room
tonight but I also want to say let's
bounce the future off of the past let's
use historical images to help shape the
future of San Francisco what do we see
in these clips that we might want to
have back or bring back and equally
important what's actually improved so
I'm saying I don't want to get caught up
in a discourse of loss I'd be happier to
talk about making the future and I'd
like to talk about history for just a
moment it's been very difficult as an
archivist I believe it's been very
difficult to get many historical records
out of their analog purgatory and it's
still hard to make new things out of
many digital archives but inevitably
we're moving toward greater access to
historical materials for people like me
archivists and historians who might or
might not have a degree this could be an
age of great promise but I would ask
this is it going to be Paris in the
1920s or Moscow in the 1920s our ideas
projects theory is going to reverberate
over decades to come or are we in a
temporary bloom before we lose our
imagination our archives our funding or
a freedom of expression this is up to us
as we expand access to historical
materials and we develop new tools to
touch them and transform them will
people care one of the things I'm
noticing at least in my field is that
actual historical images are starting to
take second place to reconstructions and
simulations you know simulations can be
more immersive they can show events from
angles where there were no cameras they
can bring in sound where none was
taken and they can fit into newly shot
material much more cleanly and I know
you know producers are always thinking
why use old clips when you can build
fancier new ones on the desktop right so
in this scheme historical material all
of our archives they become just
templates for reconstruction and the
original images can fade into obscurity
now simulations can be cool but I worry
about replacing original records with
reconstructions because we only have one
chance a single chance to document an
event and we have infinite opportunities
to reconstruct it the way it never was
and given time fictional narratives have
a funny way of pushing actual narratives
into the background you know not only do
we believe what we want to believe or
what's convenient for us to believe but
I think the more vivid stories get the
greater their power is to drive the
actual stories out of public memory this
has been and could be dangerous I hope
that easy access to the historical
record and it's getting a lot easier you
know history is going to be part of our
infrastructure it'll be all around us it
already is with some of the new
augmented reality apps I hope that easy
access to the historical record doesn't
foster indifference towards history I
hope that an overabundance of facts
doesn't distance us further from
knowledge I hope that the simultaneous
past and present that we can now
experience if we want to doesn't cause
us to substitute ambience for
consequence to separate causes from
effects but as we see as we're gonna see
tonight there's something very special
about actual historical images that no
simulation can match so finally this is
a critical moment for archives there are
many archives in this country and many
of them do uncommonly great work but a
lot of them don't have the resources to
collect and preserve everything that
they should individuals and community
groups frequently step in where archives
can't or won't save historical materials
and maybe even worse most archives lack
the resources or the mindset to actively
push collections back out to the
like archives sometimes seem like places
where the historical record goes to die
I think they should instead be places of
origin where new works are born and old
works are rebirthed so we need to help
archives do their work better and you
know I've got 900 of you archivally
conscious to some degree or other so
this is my plea this means advocating
for historical consciousness as the
world accelerates and helping archives
get the support they need to stay open
and flourish and as citizens we need to
accept some of the responsibilities for
collecting and preserving history and
not simply expect others to save it all
just because we think they're out there
be your own archivist everyone should be
their own archivist and it's because of
citizen archivists and collectors that
tonight that tonight's show contains
about 75 to 80 percent new material you
know in previous years it's been like 40
or 50 percent new some of you in the
audience and others who aren't here
tonight have generously given us film or
shared your family films with us I thank
you all and if you don't see it this
year you'll probably see it next year I
also want to especially thank the
California Historical Society for giving
me access to their Moving Image
collection which really hasn't been seen
before so you're gonna see the results
and finally remember this is an
interactive show you are the soundtrack
the majority of the material is silent
and you goaded by the commentators up in
the balcony you are responsible for
asking questions for shouting out IDs
for discussions for rants this is not
Church you are the soundtrack so let's
begin and thanks so much
[Applause]
you remember mr. this has become a
tradition with every year screening but
this is mr. John summers member of the
the Shriners Lodge who shot a rather
gorgeous Kodachrome movie little palsy
but still gorgeous of San Francisco in
summer 1941 and here he is flying in
take a look at that Treasure Island this
is going to be important later there
will be a question we're coming in to
SFO you never really know do you yeah
are the house lights bothering you can
we let's bring them down a little bit
would that be possible
how's that I'd love
yes I'd like that you know - yes
here's a model for the future what year
was SFO built Mills field I believe
around 30 31 earlier and here it is
about 1930 that's where I park my car
and this is the old Bayshore highway
congestion pricing needed
it's about 1962
San Francisco a city that promises you
something and keep their promise
a city that dares you to discover her
for us in your own way on your own terms
for no matter who you are or where you
come from or what you like to do
something exciting and wonderful and
different happens to you in San
Francisco about 1945-46 tourists
I think we're still having problems with
raccoons today these are films from the
California Historical Society that I
don't think have been seen much if at
all since 4546
that's a bird for nineteen forty-five or
forty-six this is a Russian ship in port
and the Matson lines pier and I believe
a French ship I know this is the lolani
and Matson ship
you know watch out for tarantulas and
longshoremen the leaders of the radical
labor movement in San Francisco
now this is the short-lived air ferry
between the East Bay and San Francisco
this was um no it really is this this
operated until 1933 and when a fatality
put them out of business and this you
know I'm kind of trying to stay away
from the whole Fisherman's Wharf thing
but this is the late 20s or early 30s
before it was heavily commercialized and
I think it's quite neat louder sorry
this I put in for gray Bracken now okay
we're here sometime around 45 46 and
Treasure Island's burning up I was
unable to find anything out on this does
anybody know looks like the great tire
fire yeah you're gonna have to yell I'm
sorry okay testing hasn't anything
interesting perfect never missed
anything this is footage that comes
through the courtesy of mr. Scott Stark
and shot what do you think around the
late 30s I believe we'll see them later
in living color
and Yerba Buena Island that color Oh
what here's some tourists about 1959
this is a bit unusual this clip and
you'll see why
you could see inmates in the yard Wow
here's another ferry ride this is a lot
earlier this is um I'm gonna say around
30 what what stage of the bridge is this
33 34 maybe still not done
somebody had to say that
scenes from Rankin Hill I'm beginning to
realize a lot of people climb the hill
to pose in front of the new bridge you
see this scene quite a lot
that's a big bridge and the key system
here
oh the key system was the interurban
railway that ran into the Transbay
terminal as we see in 1941 but they also
operated ferries and let's shed a tear
Transbay terminal all right
imagine we once had why did they tear
down that beautiful freeway get right to
Chinatown it was tough this is 2nd
Street towards Bryan is that what
David's telling me behind ya
rail traffic
I think the films going backwards Rick
that's on second Street right yeah and
this is the Barbary Coast around 1914
some of you may have seen this clip I've
used it before but I couldn't avoid
using it again it's um it's not clear
whether this comes from a dramatic film
or in actuality film there there's a
tiny bit of narrative but you know it
only takes two frames for there to be a
narrative so I don't you'll see in a
moment but it's probably Pacific sailors
on the town
inside exactly Don't Ask Don't Tell and
now we're in 1931 and the neighborhood's
become derelict this is movie this film
was shot by Rick lobster's family Rick
runs the Market Street Railway and our
fabulous historic streetcars and has
family had a tie for the urban landscape
pretty early
and we're gonna spend a few minutes
revisiting the G family again this year
Kathy G and her two of her cousins are
here as well and I think this is such
Commodore Stockton school thank you
these are rides at Playland at the beach
Playland was where the Safeway is at the
beach and some condominiums in front of
it
and now we're in the richmond district
who's this get a unicycle one less tire
is this a Washington High School prom
yeah go Eagles
that's the call bulletin
we're just kids hard is that no in the
higher elevations up on Mir alarm oh
yeah it's up on Portola right miss Mira
Loma cafe some of you may remember the
streets of San Francisco episode shot on
that block and this is um this is 15th
Avenue when it was an exciting place to
live it still is those kids aren't given
any money
that's right a coven grow after
centuries there have been cities that
fascinated the human mind and inspired
its creative impulses cities that had a
flavor all their own attracting painters
and poets storytellers and musicians and
nourishing their imaginations San
Francisco is such a severe begun is a
Spanish mission and military settlement
in 1776 it became a seaport city almost
overnight when gold was discovered in
the Sierra Hills in 1848 as the city
grew it retained and enriched its world
borne traditions of tolerance
hospitality and good living with its
warps and Hills its people from many
lands and it's notable sophistication it
has held unceasing fascination for those
to whom at great city wellmaybe a lively
many sided place of happy adventure of
beauty and of inspiration have you ever
experienced the astounding sight of San
Francisco's cable cars elsewhere means
of transportation of prosaic utilities
but then San Francisco is different it
seems and activities constantly reveal
the unusual between in the beauty the
wonder that artists from all parts of
the world have come to live and work in
San Francisco
many of them live on telegraph fields
they're colorful houses and flats perch
like boats on the steep sides of the
hill above the waterfront this smiling
Chinese worked as a hospital cook only a
few years ago now he is considered one
of the finest watercolorists in America
this is Don Dadda with another painter a
young American of Greek descent he
walked down the hill to find a place
suitable for sketchy
the babe when it's silvery spam and
ships from all the seas has always
offered an exciting challenge to San
Francisco painters dong attended art
school at night and to what he learned
of Western technique the added the
secrets of brush drawing as they've been
handed down among the Chinese through
many centuries
San Francisco is a city of spectacular
surprises within a stone's throw of the
busy downtown section in a continuation
of the very street we see there is
Sunday calm stillness and the nostalgic
atmosphere of bygone days
and the attics and upper stories of
high-ceilinged old-fashioned buildings
housing wine warehouses in small Brubeck
tourism studios have mushroomed breaking
with skylights into the monotony of
black tired roof
once the studio was a storage loft and
the artist first moved in years ago
spiders had spun elaborate webs and
water peek through the ceiling the
artists cleaned out the cobwebs repaired
the leaks and filled the place with
canvases and paint boxes brushes and
flats but otherwise he left it as it was
before
[Music]
of all places housing artists in the
city and the Montgomery block has the
oldest tradition behind these barrack
windows George Stirling wrote some of
his finest poems
frec Norris wrote novels here and so did
Charles and Kathleen Lawrence once this
massive building of brick and stone
contained San Francisco's first law
library once high-headed wax moustached
lawyers and stockbrokers at offices here
but in the 90s artists began to move in
now it's now a severe problem more
artists live in the Montgomery block
then what could find living under any
roof elsewhere in the country
the rent is low there is romance at the
building's past and there is always
another artist next door from whom to
borrow a brush or some pastel twice a
week the sculptor comes to the art
school to teach a younger generation the
meaning and the technique of his art
he's brawling down one of the slopes of
Russian Hill with spacious studios and
Gardens the California School of Fine
Arts is the second oldest Art School in
America the very atmosphere of its
location overlooking the Latin Quarter
and the bay is inspiring to young people
in their study of the Arts Latin Quarter
was North Beach and Columbus
Montgomery block was torn down for a
parking
I think that was the first analysis of
the San Francisco hipster Taylor Street
Market Street the east/west dividing
line is the favorite starting point for
exploring expeditions that fan out all
over the peninsula buying flowers at
Stan's north of market is a daily custom
everybody wears the flower
especially the smartly dressed women who
come to shop for to lunch in the heart
of San Francisco's fashionable shopping
district that surrounds the city's
central meeting place Union Square
[Music]
this is an early 60s promo for American
Airlines doesn't have a lot of words in
everything
[Music]
used to be for tracks across Market
Street or the floor and this was the
streetcar strike what year was that 49 I
believe that people parked on market
like they're in church
I thought they were torn out earlier
than that
now I figured you've all seen then
beautiful 1906 films that we're not
going to focus on that tonight but it's
easily available online instead we're
gonna look at about 50 years later yeah
this is mid market all the theaters that
were there Civic Center Hotel
that's a Gary Carr coming in there they
should bring streetcars back to Gary
Street the 38 is the busiest transit
line west of the Mississippi don't worry
soon they're gonna have Bart there
that's what they told us in the 50s
remember when sees was deliciously fresh
so this is early 30s and somebody's
dancing the hula in the middle of Market
Street you tell me that's right
we'll revisit this crowd a little bit
later that hair is an achievement so um
this is an outtake from a radical film
made about 1968 69 I believe it's from a
film called off the pigs and it shows
member of members of the Black Panther
Party posturing in the Western Addition
Fulton right yeah yeah this is the
fashionable Alamo Square area the source
of this clip is it's an outtake that was
given to me by California newsreel which
is the descendant of newsreel the
collective that made the film in the 60s
paste is more permanent there's Kirby's
this is uh Divisadero and Fulton
that's of course Huey Newton in the
chair by the way in Emory Douglass's art
and some of you may remember liner
liquor lobby now the fly bar 762 to
visit arrow
this is also film our street um can
somebody talk a little bit about the
gravity cars I'm not an expert counter
I'm not an expert either but basically
one car would come down and I believe it
pulled the other one up is that right I
think so this this was a two-car cable
car line they had one on Castro Street
too right yes which was strapped for
surplus for a recycled during the war it
was a regular one it wasn't a gravity ok
Castro was not a gravity my dad
I think it was late 30s but I I I don't
know and this film is through the
courtesy of the losing key family and
we'll see some more of their rather
amazing footage it's it's footage that
was shot by mrs. Liu zenki who was born
Catherine Bailey and her and and Victor
losing key and it's um they were just
hanging around Joe DiMaggio's wedding is
that what's going on 20,000 people came
to the wedding I mean not that we're not
invited
[Laughter]
Jefferson Street
the newsreel cameramen move in to cover
it
hey I got a restaurant we can have our
reception at
there I think there in front of his
restaurant
so every year at Mayday the the pupils
of San Francisco dancing schools turned
out sometimes in Golden Gate Park and
today I think this is Kezar and this is
a very big deal
anybody know who that is
Elmer Robertson Elmer Robinson was the
mayor nearly 50 this I think is just
after the war
and this is a parade to support the
allies I believe this is 1942 41 perhaps
mr. losing he can correct me we don't
have an exact date established yet but
these are all representatives of the
Allied countries
Lowe's Forbidden City Malta
and these are the free French this is
the cross of Lorraine and here we move
to Khizar Stadium these are films from
the same family this is a rather amazing
event go Niners
Wow Judah ben-hur would have no chance
against this our work is done we're
gonna get the children's carousel
tomorrow and this is a again just after
World War 2 the cable cars have been
decorated for Christmas
I cut that down from about six minutes
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
we're building the dreams for tomorrow
we're building a dream for tomorrow
five dollars to be point and sunshine
touches every hand in parks where
children play
over the hills and all along
we're building the dream for the far
we're building so wicked earworms
bicycles in the last cars in three
counties Bart is building a high-speed
rail Rapid Transit System planned for
your convenience designed for your
comfort and deliberately aimed at giving
you a safer faster more economical ride
than your automobile fully aware as
Lewis Mumford says that the city exists
not for the constant passage of
motorcars but for the care and culture
of men heavy concrete's wilds of
free-weight freeways that carry the
extravagance of one car one passenger
mostly at a standstill
instead Bart trains carrying thousands
of comfortably seated passengers will
glide successfully through the bay to
under the Ferry Building and into the
Market Street subway when you climb
across Market Street or ride a bus
that's been detoured remember that your
surface difficulties are temporary still
not done while the low ground and in the
other two urban core cities Oakland and
Berkeley 975 sandhogs are tunneling 21
miles of subway and when it's completed
you and the Bay Area will not only feel
better you both look better
in the holosuite station you look along
the way you may stop at a magazine stand
by commute tickets from the automatic
vending machine enjoy the clean spacious
architect-designed station so on the
marina green late 20s or early 30s this
some footage comes to us through the
courtesy of Thad Povey who I hope is
here thank you that was a it was a gas I
don't know how that works we always had
that gas stuff works a gas ometer it
expands and contracts with a it's the
marina Safeway now isn't it
and this is I think 4849 the Freedom
Train traveled around the country with
the documents of freedom and parked on
their Marina Green that came out in the
70s - I went to the marina I mean the
Freedom Train
the fog here has a beauty all its own
ribs and billows in from the sea thick
and silent here the fog is seldom
sinister or depressing as you may know
it elsewhere they have a special kind of
fog that befits a special kind of city a
city with a fabled landmark that is
known the world over the Golden Gate the
Golden Gate of San Francisco and this is
some more early post-war material
six dollars paying to leave yeah
they don't even have the little yellow
things dividing them you're not supposed
to be here
Oh Steinhart aquarium the old DeYoung
museum
oh you don't you like the rusty aircraft
carrier they got now the DeYoung
Memorial Museum is popular with the boys
of the army they all stop at the gun
room which traces the development of
weapons through the centuries up to the
modern tank
[Music]
you see that the young is essentially of
people's Museum it is a family Museum it
is the kind of place people enjoy in the
way they enjoy stories of distant lands
in bygone days to stroll through these
galleries does something to you
time and space contract if it weren't
for the guards about you could
practically touch what by right belongs
in other centuries and other parts of
the globe
[Music]
mr. DeYoung intended it to always be
free and he's dead
strawberry strawberry island and I
believe it's the very early 30s these
rocks are still there people in the 30s
had such small feet but the fountain is
no longer you no longer this has been
cemented over and there's a new bridge
thank God
so this family kind of drank there with
this I don't know if it's a family these
hipsters kind of drank their way through
the Bay Area but they didn't do very
much of it in San Francisco but I did my
best to find you a little bit of
Prohibition era inebriation that's one
of the things you find in prohibition of
home movies that people are constantly
shooting it shooting themselves drinking
wasn't that the deer hunter this is what
I get for sharing my family films with
you
just need a snack
[Laughter]
and we're by one of the lakes in the
park
now in those days you needed a
prescription to buy liquor legally
remember
it's true
it depends
[Laughter]
Buffalo there bison I counted 20 I might
be off by one or two but they were the
herd was seemed a lot healthier back
then they used to have deer and sheep in
the park yes that's right this is from
the collection of mr. Scott Stark
luxe College 17th in Potrero what's that
building now the Hawks school merged
with lick and Wilmerding I think so now
it's all like Wilmerding Lex was the
girl school
we're just gonna see one of the models
today because you know we can't be here
all night
so this is a sequence only was made by
me I don't like it sometimes these pants
are a bit
I leave it is contemplated on like I
laugh so much my country I love so much
my family and my people they might want
either Mexico Nicaragua and Salvador I
like it
we people have to work too much we have
to work because we pay too much money
and they raise any time they want why
don't they get out of the band boys they
have a bigger plan that is defined by
the corporate giants to make part of the
mission Wall Street West they're going
to build a financial district within the
mission they intend to move out all the
brown people as an unskilled labor class
this is part of a mass extermination of
a people in my head I believe the
Spanish people come with the color
people so termination discontent
discrimination F discrimination this
conference is true guys discrimination
this country I know I did quite a few
Mexican because you know anybody told me
you know Mexican is bad and Mexican
these days and making it is bad you know
I have to be a Mexican sometimes before
I use the fuel I didn't want to go out
with my mother no place not anyone about
the supermarket with her I didn't have
water on a picnic water
being bad plays you know because he was
a Mexican man I wish it was securities
because I'm a shame of myself because I
thought the problems that their older
sons are going we're going to go first
of all second of all we have no money to
go to the places that they want us to go
for example the you know bowling alleys
in the car races in the horse how did
you know like um are these you know like
where you can spend money yet so where
do we go we go to the booth ha
[Music]
you know the looser pace the time in are
these so after we spend all the money we
so this film was made as part of a
campaign to free seven men who were
arrested for the shooting of a police
officer on Alvarado Street they were
acquitted a year or two later called las
siete dasa this is this is now the
hipster the hipster mall Pete's Rick
this incarnation is hipster heavy we saw
this last year I couldn't resist putting
it again it's from Scott stark and David
Gallagher has takes the credit for
discovering that this is the
intersection of Monterey San Jose a view
induced and in Glen Park this is what
about nineteen thirty nine ish I believe
and this is the beauty of Kodachrome
which if it's kept cool and dry we'll
look this way for a couple hundred years
if you have any Kodachrome get it in by
the end of the year because the last lab
is closing down the production line this
month Thank You Kerry December 30th the
Duane's photo in Kansas
these are the same people that took the
ferry ride at the beginning
when home movies show people doing their
jobs that's always kind of a doubly
fascinating and this is a family
business as well so there's just lots
going on here
this may be the young rig lab sure I'm
not a hundred percent sure but this is
what sunset heights okay so it's
somewhere between 1918 and 1920 and this
is the Sunset District glider club and
we're gonna see it a couple times and I
think some people in the balcony have
some idea where this may be shot well
you know we'd heard a lot about the
gliders and I was just hoping that in my
lifetime I would see a picture of them I
never thought I'd see them in film you
think you knew where that was Megan
telling me there's one shot where it
looks like it's looking north over the
park towards the Richmond from maybe
Golden Gate Heights maybe mid-20s
but I we may have missed that shot
already we'll see it slowed down in a
moment but this is footage of the dunes
before they were fully built out there
there we go
so we're thinking maybe that building
that large building we saw in the
background is the old Conservatory of
Music Building which was on Ortega and
19th Avenue originally was a orphanage
called the infant shelter and it was
built around 1918 I think so would be
quite new yeah and it was off in the
distance
looking more east when they panned back
this was a piece of film that showed up
in a basement and on 23rd Avenue and it
needs some help
aha and this comes to us from the
western neighborhoods project it's a
film made by misterpost who shot a lot
of the very early San Francisco films
you see people used to think he shot
Market Street 1906 but he did not and
it's introducing Westwood Park this is a
Miramar Avenue at Ocean Avenue today
looking north
and away you go
so this neighborhood was made accessible
by the opening of the Twin Peaks tunnel
it was developed by a Baldwin and Howell
and it was a bungalow community it was
all bungalows which were an
architectural rage at the time so if you
don't know her Westwood Park is it's
just west of where City College is north
of Ocean Avenue in the land of fog and
stucco
that house is still there it's on South
Gate and Miramar
the cross was burned when the first
black family moved in that neighborhood
in the sixties that was Ingleside
terraces which is close to here and
behind it's all Sutro square that's
still there that's Java notion at Faxon
if you've had a coffee there
Faxon in Ocean Avenue yeah it's nice
place and that's the where the Walgreens
parking lot is this was an early movie
theater it was called the Balboa and
then when the Balboa theater opened on
Balboa Street it was called the new
Balboa
oh really that's where the fruit barn is
this buildings still there
and that's sutra forest it went all the
way over the hill down mount Davidson
and they cut all those trees to build
Westwood Highlands and Monterey Heights
this is farther up the hill and Westwood
Highlands what do you want to do I don't
know what do you want to do it's cold
it's foggy it's freezing
don't go uphill
some of the fondest memories of the city
recall San Francisco at night after the
skyline has been painted gold by a
Pacific sunset them under the night sky
it puts on a bright new costume like a
dancer before the footlights Chinatown
bursts into brilliant color and her
pagodas rise from a lake of light filled
with bustle and laughter
[Music]
Fisherman's Wharf is ready to serve its
discriminating diners until the small
hours of the morning and San Franciscans
to whom good food is a part of good
living congregate in the city's famous
restaurants
[Music]
dishes are prepared here by chefs whose
sauces salads and meats bear the honored
approval of their brother chefs in
Europe
[Music]
San Francisco youngest of the renowned
cities of world reputation stamped with
a mixed culture from both East and West
and Barry on her Seven Hills the
ultimate of charm and beauty
[Music]
but we're here at flash hacker pool yeah
that's the bathhouse six million gallons
of seawater
it's the zoo parking lot today cold yes
they had promotional shots where they'd
have lifeguards in row boats actually
having to Patrol
fly shockers closed for good in 71 I
think it was they had a ballot
initiative to try to save it and it
failed so the Legion of Honor was only a
year too old when this was filmed
the Legion of Honor was built on an old
cemetery and when they did renovations
in 94 they found a whole bunch of bodies
highly recommend Trina Lopez's film on
her cemeteries what's it called the last
the second final rest and this is um
Sutra heights park probably year two
before the mansion was torn down but
unfortunately the mansion is absent in
this in this film
[Laughter]
right in front of the sign
that was some pretty exciting footage
great highway um briefly little bit and
we're right after the war again here
lots of cars that pier was a water pipe
that sucked up the ocean water and
pumped it all the way down to Bush and
Larkin Street for the Olympic salt water
company they used it to bathe in down
there this is the sky tram and the
Whitney brothers who owned the Cliff
House and Playland they decided they
were going to add this amusement and it
went from the cliff house over across
where Sutro Baths is that little cove to
the rocky outcrop I look across it went
about three miles an hour and it was
only like 500 yards long it wasn't very
popular it was it opened in the 50s it
lasted about five years I think the sand
is has risen up above all those steps
now most everywhere this is our annual
tribute to Playland I would love it if
any of you have Playland films to help
me change the footage a little bit and
I'm especially looking for footage of
Sutro Baths that it turns out outside of
a the Hollywood film that takes place
there there's very little home movie
footage of Sutro Baths the line up it's
on YouTube the sequence it's well worth
looking at
laughing Sal and this is um care to tell
you after Playland clothes the
destruction is 72 closed I think
September 72 yeah yeah that's mentioned
in the movie that's been running at the
Balboa there's a good movie at the
Playland at the beach movie why did it
closed deteriorating interest over time
it's a long story really but a developer
wanted to build on it and it had kind of
gotten run down that's the old pump
house that took the seawater out down to
Bush and Larkin
this is Playland so they're destroying
all the old buildings and rides it's
funny we have some footage on our
website of the auction they had before
they closed it and you could have got
this huge Alpine Racer roller coaster
for a hundred bucks
all condominiums now in a safe way a
little bit of the front of suit rose
this is sometime in the 30s
and the fabulous Sutro Baths let's build
him again yes I believe that we're
actually in a airship
these are outtakes from a film made by
the Convention and Visitor's Bureau oh
you know that depicts between 56 and 62
it's very very fluid when this was shot
I can't tell you exactly why did the
bass class they had gotten run down they
they stopped making money too
people didn't want to go bathing inside
there anymore they cut it
they cut the bathing they put an ice
skating rink in they tried a lot of
different things and then supposedly it
may have been arson but when they were
starting to tear it down the whole thing
burned and a big fire in 66 so I
couldn't end the program without taking
us to the farallon's which is actually
in San Francisco it's in supervisorial
district one although I don't think
anybody votes there this is some time in
the 40s and 50s it's a little hard to
say it looks very very different now
they're they've taken out many of the
buildings although the crane has has
also been replaced that's the only way
you get up is by being hoisted up but
it's certainly one of the most
interesting and hardest to step on parts
of San Francisco and it's fishing trip
oh don't eat that
[Applause]
pretty good thanks to all of them and
thanks to all of you for coming
just a couple questions Rick one is you
have so much more stuff this year is
that because you're getting a lot more
stuff coming in as the traffic
increasing or what it's this is the
Beast I have to feed every year to get
more material it's really really
difficult and even in the fall I was a
little worried about it but people have
been incredibly generous and many of
some of these I've acquired myself but
the show has been made by people's
contributions
keep them coming yeah we're gonna move
on to several things I wanted to thank
Natalie Ric and the fabulous work of
everybody 20 in this material our
panelists at Holmes woody Labonte Megan
Allison Wade and our staunchest who's
left
Susanne Ramsay thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you